[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors en préambule cette phrase est
dédié à mes collègues confrères et
néanmoins amis que quelques propos
peuvent peut-être par ailleurs choqué
alors qui dit match
dix équipes premières équipes équipe
santé qui me sentais chef de file les
médecins les médecins l'art médical un
art ancestral 2011 en rendez vous compte
une science qu'elle a essayé d'extraire
les élus de la sorcellerie par un
enseignement extrêmement l'on critique
une pensée hypothétique négative nous
faisons toujours un diagnostic par
élimination d'ailleurs ça s'appelle un
techniques d'élimination bon mais c'est
pas que ça on n'est quand même pas tout
à fait larguer vous faire un petit peu
numérique quand même tenez
téléconsultation c'est pas
extraordinaire à l'heure actuelle entre
une station spatiale et la terre on peut
communiquer on peut faire des
diagnostics confirmer l'hypothèse
diagnostic on peut prendre des rendez
vous par internet on peut consulter ces
rendez vous sur le net c'est pas
extraordinaire se voir même avoir
personnellement un dossier médical
numérisés jeu extraordinaire bon face de
nous une équipe jeune dynamique l'équipe
digitale
alors là ils ont été très très fort une
stratégie à toute épreuve
en vingt ans ils ont su imposer
exactement tout ce qu'ils voulaient nous
apprendre à recevoir des données nous
apprendre à communiquer nous apprendre à
accepter que nos data soit utilisée très
très fort très puissant alors c'est une
équipe avec des joueurs solides vraiment
une attaque impeccable une défense
incroyable dit pleurs ning toujours très
beau très très bons blocs scène en
défense rien à redire
et le summum du summum a reçus il ya
tout le mercato pourrait bien se le
prendre c'est big data alors big data
dans un match nous ont fait pas le poids
fatalement pas le poids que on en a ri
pensez vous imaginez un robot médecin a
battu en fait il ya déjà des robot
chirurgien au bassin c'est bien fait
pour eux là franchement ça écart faire
plus attention à ce qu'ils faisaient
pour vous dire vrai la médecine on n'a
rien vu venir
alors on était complètement pris dans un
problème à une problématique récurrente
de maîtrise des coûts de virage
ambulatoire qu'on voulait pas rater
mais gêné sortie de route à la une des
journaux non impossible impossible
les réseaux de soins à construire et ce
fameux dossier informatisé patients il
fallait sortir des limbes pour le rendre
accessible au plus grand nombre
est-ce que vous qui connaît la médecine
des 5 p pour un choix que je suis pas la
seule
eh ben la médecine et 5 pc ce que je
suis censé en tant que professeur
enseigne et déjà vous vous connaissez
pas comment voulez-vous que mes
étudiants connaissent
eh ben la médecine détrempée c'est une
médecine personnalisée une médecine
prédictive une pressing préemptive une
pression très lente yves et enfin
participative
c'est ce que nous promet le numérique
sauf que moi je sais pas comment
l'enseigner parce que je sais déjà parce
que c'est mais je suis pas la seule ça
me rassure oups alors août et roots et
je vais vous dire pourquoi roots
quand on est médecin on porte serment
mais toutes les professionnels de santé
le fonds est dedans on doit s'assurer et
on lui jure on le jure que on va faire
nos soins avec une grande qualité une
grande équité et surtout une grande
confidentialité alors là là moi je vais
vous dire je pense qu on a vendu notre
âme au diable
on apprend perd on perd tout ça
et puis pour vous en convaincre je vais
vous raconter une histoire très
personnelle mais je sais que parmi vous
il y en a chez qui ça va faire écho
directement ou indirectement
il ya quelques temps j'ai eu la bonne
idée de voir apparaître une tache sur la
cuisse toutes petites tâches qui tâche
moins d'une pièce de 5 centimes des
câbles mais une tech une tâche comme on
dit avec un délit de sale tête
donc je dis je vais prendre rendez-vous
en dermato pas de problème d'autant
mieux que je suis pas quand même un
grand cadors en dermato j'ai passé trois
fois le certificat
donc j'appelle servi de dermato service
d'amato à une voie électronique
alors pour prendre rendez vous tapez sur
un en cas d'urgence taper sur deux non
c'est bon c'est une urgence
personnellement fin on va à relativiser
je vais rester calmes ont à prendre
rendez vous donc je tape un si vous
voulez prendre rendez vous merci de vous
rendre sur le site internet alapage
consultation et de remplir le formulaire
pas bon mais chez plus personne qui me
répond à l'hôpital bon on va pas de
problème alors je vais sur le site
internet rubrique prise de rendez-vous
sous rubriques dermatologie je prends
donc mandu et un monde il faut étayer la
demande est ce que tout le monde combien
ce que ça veut dire étayer la demande
alors je dis là là je vais me la jouer
professeurs ça tombe bien je vais
essayer maintenant donc je refais une
belle de londres concise
je leur rappelle la règle des 5 baies de
la tumeur de pau tour jeudi là quand
même j'ai passé mon examen ce je vais
réussir cette fois ci je le réussis
tellement bien que 48 heures à paris
miracle je reçois un texto avec mon
rendez vous dans trois mois
bah ça tombe bien je rage avait pas
piscine donc je prends le rendez-vous
dieu merci trois mois tout le monde me
du tournoi mais tu échoues de ses
habitudes ses six à neuf mois tu as dû
vraiment été é temps dossier ok ok mais
bon
donc j'ai donc rendez vous j'en parle
évidemment à mes proches de ce petit
souci de moins de 5
l'un d'eux me allez on peut dire une
demie pièce de 5 centimes
et là je reçois un jour un coup de fil
de ma soeur ma soeur la voix grave
dominique tu vas pas mourir je suis bien
désolé de te l'apprendre mais un jour ça
m'arrivera tu sais pas tout de suite
mais non mais tu compte pas mourir dans
les cinq ans non non j'ai d'autres
choses à faire je pourquoi tu me dis ça
parce que j'étais sur internet il
malheureuse pas creuse on ne va jamais
il sur internet c'est sûr de tomber
malade quand tu vas sur internet elle me
dit tu sais j'ai regardé site
extrêmement sérieux tu as entre 5 % et
95 % de décéder dans les cinq ans pareil
je lis tu sais quand je traverse la
route j'ai à peu près la même proportion
unités mais ça laisse quand même une
marge entre 5 et 95% je pense quand même
que j'ai un peu de marge au 1000m dit
tout ça tu sais le mélanome est le
cancer le plus agressif de l'adulte
jeune mais moi j'avais pas vécu ça du
tout comme ça j'avais pas vu je l'avais
pas vu comme ça ennjimi la différence
entre 5 et 95% elle aussi est très étayé
ses 2 mm ah bon m écoutent avec star
tant mieux mais je vais peut-être me
référer ce qu'on va me dire l'hôpital
bon enfin bref l'hôpital effectivement
biopsie là tout ce qui va avec examens
complémentaires et je reçois un courrier
ferez-vous dans ma boîte aux lettres ou
là on me mom informe qu'un staff
multidisciplinaire s'est réuni à mon
sujet à mon sujet sans moi et oui ils se
sont réunis donc à mon sujet et sans moi
et ils ont décidé que je devais venir
les voir tous les trois mois bah ça
tombe bien j'ai pas encore piscine d'eau
et trois mois donc me voilà donc affublé
avec un une page de rendez vous je sais
ce que je fais dans l'esprit première
prochaines années
les câbles j'ai tout j'ai tout tout tout
est bien enfin par courrier imaginez
c'est tombé dans la boîte aux lettres du
voisin ils ouvraient enfin je n'ai pas
spécialement envie que tout le monde
voit mes données médicales
puis bon j'aurais aimé qu'on me le dise
où j'aurai peut-être même aimé qu'on
m'invite je pas plus bêtes que les
autres j'aurais pu comprendre coach que
j'étais pas bonne en d1 dermato mais
j'aurais pu leur enseigner des questions
parce que dans mon dossier des questions
qui sont vides comme par exemple je vais
peut-être vous l'apprendre le mélanome
on a un facteur de risque d'avoir un
mélanome si dans la famille on a vu
quelqu'un qui a eu une tumeur du tube
neural bon c'est pas dans toutes les
familles vrai mais moi c'est blanc parce
qu'on l'a jamais posé comme question
donc comment faire un diagnostic sans
avoir toutes les données en soi sachant
que c'est un diagnostic d'élimination
bon on va pas continuer à parler de ma
vie
continuons donc la digital 400t 06 ont
rejoué le match tarde sont donnés ce
challenge parce que la santé elle sera à
digital ça c'est clair on va pas y
couper
par contre est peut-être des choses
peut-être des choses qu'on pourrait
faire pour modifier tout ça et si la
solution venait du fait qu'on arrive à
modifier notre chaîne de valeur alors je
vous passe à l'heure actuelle il ya un
truc qu'on est sûr c'est que la
population sera de plus en plus
vieillissante
premièrement ce que l'on est sûr c'est
que il ya une épidémie mondiale de
maladies chroniques
donc les patients potentiellement que
l'on aura face de nous ce qu'on des
personnes avec des pathologies
chroniques peut être multiple et des
personnes âgées
donc la chaîne de valeur elle est certes
numérique d'un côté pour tout ce qui est
ultra spécialisation génétique autres
mais pour toute cette population qu'elle
sera humaine et notre spécificité notre
spécialisation
elle sera dans la médecine de proximité
et la médecine de proximité ça
sous-entend prendre en compte toutes les
chaînes
la chaîne professionnelle
l'interprofessionnalité est entre autres
le soin infirmier qui va être centrale
au milieu de tout ça première chose la
chaîne de valeur doit changer
à ce niveau là mais doit changer aussi
en acceptant que le passant qui mieux
que soi même ne connaît sa pathologie
personnes donc il faut aussi intégrer
dans cette chaîne de valeur des soins et
des réflexions les patients première
solution
et si la solution venait moi tout
simplement de mieux former nos étudiants
rappelez-vous la médecine est un truc de
vieux de mille cinq cents ans enseignée
par des vieux à des jeunes
voyez le tableau ces jeunes là alors
donc moi je leur ai transmis
l'idée il fallait penser
hypothétiquement négatif et en face on a
toute une bande de petits rigolos qui
eux pensent en algorithmes a déjà sa
match pas on peut en parler ensemble
l'algorithme mais l'hypothèse n'a rien à
voir donc moi je dis dors et déjà il
faut qu'à nous étudiants on intègre le
fait qu'ils pensent algorithmique
il pensa t fille qui pense informatique
c'est pas parce qu'ils sont digital
natives qu'ils ont forcément cette
appétence et cette connaissance
suffisante pour être de vrais acteurs du
changement donc mieux former nos
étudiants peut-être c'est une solution
dernière hypothèse
ce serait de créer des lieux ça serait
sage at aurait cru créer des lieux
disruptif d'innovation des lieux hors
norme des lieux qui viendrait compléter
ce qu'il existe des dispositifs actuels
sont nombreux on a des incubateurs on a
du corps qui aura des plateformes on a
beaucoup de choses mais est ce que
vraiment l'humain est entré dedans je me
pose une question
alors peut-être que tu essaies lieu hors
norme pour des réflexions en dehors de
la boîte soit peut-être la solution pour
qu'au final la santé sera digital les
qu'on gagne on sera tous gagnants vous
moi on sera tous gagnants professionnels
de santé patients en soit tous gagnants
de cette avancée extraordinaire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]